Sophie was diagnosed with severe
obsessive-compulsive disorder when she
was nine a decade on she's now learned
to manage the condition but at its worst
it left her Paralyzed by fear I'd feel
like confined on the couch like I
couldn't touch even a pillow that was
right next to me because it was
contaminated with whatever I was worried
about with school I had a six hour
shower completely like using bottles of
shower gel shampoo
um and then even afterwards like not
even wanting to go into my own room I
had to be in a different room because my
room was contaminated with school
in Hal's case his OCD focused on numbers
and counting and led to so-called
rituals that lasted up to nine hours a
day it's pretty Insidious and it comes
back and raises ugly head wherever you
least expect it
um
and it's a nightmare really it's
estimated one in four 17 to 19 year olds
are now suffering serious mental
distress up from one in six last year
before covid in 2017 it was one in ten
covid has played a role and probably
quite a significant one when you think
about the disruption that children and
young people have experienced to
um their social and their family
situations and to their education as
well as just the wider uncertainty and
it means across the country the supply
of Mental Health Services is struggling
to meet demand this is the maudsley
hospital in South London the country's
leading specialists in children's and
young people's mental health but even
after being referred here the waiting
time for treatment can be as long as 16
months clinicians say it's not just the
number of referrals that's increased but
also their severity in many cases the
longer that we leave a young person
without the treatment is that that can
mean that they can get significant worse
and something that myself and my
colleagues who've been in the service
for a long time have been aware of
recently is that we are seeing
such a much higher number of really
really severely unwell young people I
came here and everything sort of started
to make sense Hal says the treatment he
received here saved his life but now
there's more young people than ever
needing help either Bennett Sky News